小伙伴们大家好,我是本次的玛丽全开特辑的讲师
深藤看技术专家宋磊
很高兴和大家在看训练营玛丽全开特辑的直播间见面
而2026看训练营我们设置了全新的四大主题课程
包括开源基础系列,玛丽全开特辑,开发者说
还有企业对话专场
同时也设置了更多好玩的互动让各位小伙伴参与
首先给大家介绍一下本季全新的训练营的玩法
大家可以先截图保存一下
玩法一,互动问答
看直播的同时,大家可以扫码到社区活动院
边看边答题
全部回答正确的前五名可以领取奖品
玩法二,客户作业
直播课程结束后,一休月会更新另外的题目
全部回答正确的前五名小伙伴可以领取定时毛毯一份
玩法三,学习笔记加直播打卡
按要求在深藤论坛发布学习心得并提交一休
就有机会获得社区的定制
回到本次的正题
本次课程主题是
详解面向深藤的Triton蒜子和调试和性能优化
然后课程主要分为以下四个部分
首先介绍一下蒜子的调试的手段
然后介绍一下蒜子性能测试的一些工具
然后第三部分是介绍蒜子调试优化的一些我们典型的案例
最后是介绍蒜子的性能优化的部分
然后首先我们来看一下蒜子的调试的有哪些手段
在介绍蒜子调试之前
我们先回顾一下Triton Kernel的开发
首先用户可以通过发射多个逻辑核
根据核数将数据切开为多个block来进行并行的运算
整个Triton Kernel是使用SPMD的开发模式
也就是说所有的逻辑核会共用同一段Triton Kernel的代码
然后Triton Kernel内会计算每一个block的数据
所以在Triton算子内部会首先要获取逻辑核的ID
然后根据ID和block size去计算我们运算的数据的目标位置
然后把对应的数据从片外内存加载到片上内存
计算之后再把数据存回片外内存
然后这个Triton Kernel在外层调用的时候
首先要创建一个Tensor把数据进行初始化
然后把对应的运算所需要的输入输出的地址
传入到这个Triton Kernel内部
然后通过Grid的参数去控制逻辑核的数量
我们来看一个具体的一个例子
这是一个这里展示了一个VectorAd的一个Kernel
然后首先我们会通过Triton.Jet去定一个Triton的内核
然后它的输入参数里面可以看到
它包含了整个Ad运算的输入输出所需要的地址
数据的地址
然后以及我们所需要运算的一个完整的一个数据的大小
还有每个逻辑核所运算的一个Block Size的大小
然后在Triton在Kernel的内部的时候
我们会先通过Program ID去获取PID
然后通过PID去运算我们所需要获取的这个数据所在的位置
然后之后通过Mask来防止我们漏的进来
我们加载到片上内存的数据超出我们总的需要计算的数据的一个大小
然后之后我们通过Tier.load
把片外内存上的一些数据load到片上内存
然后计算之后再把这些数据存到片外内存
那Titon Kernel是怎么进行调用的呢
首先我们会加载一些面向生存相关的一些组件
然后在Titon Kernel调用之前会数据化一些XY这个输入的参数
然后这些参数在初始化的时候
我们可以通过Device去控制这些参数的数据位置是在NPU上的
之后在Kernel调用之前会先计算我们所需要的逻辑核的数量
然后这里逻辑核的数量就是所有的数据的总量除以一个block size的大小
得到一个Grid的参数
然后把Grid的这个参数可以传入到这个Ad的Kernel里面去
使得数据能够在多个逻辑核上并行执行
然后我们再写整个
这是整个一个完整的一个Titon的算子的写法
然后我们可以看到如果我们想调试这个算子
在Python层面上我们可以通过Print去把输出的一些数据给打印出来
那在Kernel内部我们该怎么去调试这些数据呢
其实Titon也提供了一些DebugOP
DebugOP包括编译时的一些调试的命令
以及运行时的调试的命令
编译时调试命令分为StaticPrint
它可以打印编译时的常量值
还有StaticAssert编译时的常量值
还有StaticAssert
它是编译时针对常量表达式的断言
然后还有两个运行时的调试
运行时的调试包括DevicePrint
它可以打印变量值
但它要求前面必须要有prefix
同时需要把环境变量
TitonDevicePrint设置为1
然后DeviceAssert相比于DevicePrint
需要再额外设置一个环境变量
把TitonDebug也设置为1
之后我们来看一下这8个OP是如何使用的
而这里给了一些静态打印以及动态打印的一些例子
同样我们可以尝试在静态StaticPrint里面去打印动态的变量
以及在DevicePrint里面去打印静态的变量
看一下它输出的结果是什么样的
右侧这张图就是我们打印之后的输出结果
首先我们可以看到整个打印的分布中
StaticPrint由于是编译时期的打印
所以它是在运行时的DevicePrint的打印之前的
然后StaticPrint的打印
如果打印的是常量
BlockSize
那它可以直接打印出具体的数值
那它如果打印的是动态变量
那它只能打印出对应变量的一个数据类型
但是DevicePrint它可以打印
并行时的这个变量的值
如果它打印
它同样也可以打印出静态的这个变量值
BlockSize也能打印出128
然后同时它还可以打印动态变量
PID和X的具体数值
然后由于整个add kernel是发射在两个逻辑盒上
B型执行
然后所以整个数据大小会切分为Block0和Block1
然后DevicePrint也可以打印出
不同Block上的数据的具体的数值
除了DebugOP可以进行调试以外
还有一个是解释器模式
在CPU上进行调试
通过开启Triton Interpret等于1的环境变量
整个kernel会在解释器模式进行执行
这时候它就不会在生存上去运行
这时候我们就可以在脚本里去import PDB的组件
然后通过插入断点来进行整个算子的一个调试
然后右边也展示了一些PDB的常用的调试的命令
但是因为解释器模式性能比较差
所以我们通常拿解释器模式
所以用于看一些精度类的问题
我们常见的不同数据类型精度对比的处理策略是这样子的
就是首先看一下Float16类型
由于FloatF16类型的精度比较低
那我们允许稍大一点的误差
所以我们能够容忍千分之一的误差比较
然后BF16精度更低
我们通常建议转化为Float32的类型
然后容忍千分之一的误差进行比较
F32类型因为精度比较高
所以我们需要用更严格的一个容差
我们通常用万分之一的精度进行比较
整数类型我们就要求两个数值完全相等
布尔类型的话
由于设备间不同的布尔类型表示可能有差异
所以我们通常建议在转化到CPU上进行比较
使用单字节的结果进行比较
然后算子的潮湿部分就介绍到这里
之后我们来看一下算子性能测试的一些工具有哪些
第一个介绍的算子性能测试工具是TouchenPU Profiler
我们可以在CAN的社区上找到社区版的文档
然后选择对应的版本
找到下面的路径去查看这个TouchenPU Profiler的一个完整的
这个工具完整的一些介绍还有案例
然后我们今天主要介绍的是这个 Profiler工具的一些API参数
还有怎么使用的一个案例
首先来看一下这个TouchenPU Profiler的API以及相应的参数
它里面最关键的一个API是Profile
这个Profile的接口基本囊括了所有需要设置的参数
比如这个Activities它指示了需要采集的是CPU的数据还是NPU的数据
误人情况下是两个图是开启的
然后Schedule是指设置需要设置
指示设置不同的Step行为
也就是说我需要采集哪部分的运行的轮次的数据
这个我们后面会进行展开的介绍
然后OnTraceReady是采集结束后自动执行的操作
包括比如说数据的存储这一类
这个也是在这个TensorBoard TraceTandler这部分会进行介绍
然后是ProfileMembers
它用于只是算子的显存占用情况
默认是false就是关闭的
然后还有一个是WayStack
可以采集算子雕容站信息
默认也是false
然后RecordShapes
采集的是算子的import shape
还有import types信息
默认也是false的
最后是ExperimentalConfig
它是一些性能采集的
扩展的性能采集的数据
我们下面就可以先来看一下
这个ExperimentalConfig
这里我们主要介绍
介绍的是比较关键的几个
ExperimentalConfig的参数配置
首先是ProfilerLevel
它是把一些采集的性能指标
分成了不同的Level
比如说None就是不采集下面的
所有一些性能指标数据
Level0的话会采集上层应用数据
底层NPU数据
还有NPU上执行的算子的信息
包括NPU上执行的算子的性能耗时
还有最大最小的性能耗时等等
然后Level1的话
就是在Level0的基础上
会有外采集
AscendCL数据
还有一些性能指标信息
比如说下面的这些性能指标
像Pipe Utilization
就是一些计算单元
或者是搬运单元的耗时信息等等
然后Level2的话
就是会在Level1的基础上
还会再多采集Runtime的数据
以及框架的数据
然后由于我们常看的是
Titon Kernel的一个性能情况
所以通常使用到的是Level0
或者是Level1
第二个参数
第二个关键的参数是AIC Matrix
然后这个是性能指标的一个采集项
它可以控制
我需要采集哪些类别的性能指标
比如说NUM就是会关闭
下面所有的性能指标的采集
然后Pipe Utilization就是
比如说Cube Vector计算单元
或者是MTE的搬运单元的一些
运行耗时以及占比
然后Arismatic Utilization
是各种计算类指标占比的统计
比如说Vector的FP32的指令
它的耗时是多少
占比是多少等等
然后还有一些Memory相关的
比如说Memory
Memory L0
还有Memory UB
这些都是内存读写类指令
相关数据的采集
常见的就是采集这些读写类指令的一个带宽数据
然后Resource Conflict Ratio
采集的是流水线对裂类的指令占比
这个主要关注的是Conflict的数据
比如说产生Bank Conflict
或者是Bank Group Conflict
这类指令的一个占比情况
而L2Cache
采集的是读写Cache命中
或者是Mess后重新分配次数
然后Memory Access
采集的是算计在核上访问的带宽数据量
单位是KB
第三个参数是Data Simplification
它主要是看是否要开启数据精简模式
一般默认是开启的
这样会删除一些冗余的数据
除了这三个比较关键常用的指标以外
在那个社区的文档里面
同样还有一些其他的指标
大家可以上社区文档去看一下
然后第二部分主要介绍的是Schedule
Schedule是指示了我们到底需要采集
哪些轮次的性能数据
我们可以结合着这个参数
以及下面的图来看我们是怎么采集的
首先是设置Skip First的这个参数
这个参数表示了
我在采集前需要提前去运行
跳过哪些轮次的性能数据
然后Wait表示我每一次采集数据
每一次重复采集数据之前
首先需要跳过的Step轮数
我们Map是预热的一个Step轮数
最终我们实际性能采集的数据
是Active的这几轮
然后每一次Repeat之后
都会输出一个性能数据
放在一个文件夹里
设置了几次Repeat
就会有几个文件夹的性能数据
最终采集到的数据存放在哪里
是通过TensorBoard TraceHandler
这个参数设置的
这里面包括性能数据的存放路径
还有区分PID去进行存放的一些
性能数据的路径
然后如果Schedule里面之前介绍的Repeat
重复的次数大于1的话
那也会生成多个性能数据的文件夹
然后第三个参数Analyze Flag
是一个性能数据自动解析的开关
默认为True
也就是自动去进行解析
然后Async Mode控制了
是否需要开启一部解析
一般默认设置为False
也就是我们同步会进行解析
API和参数介绍完之后
我们先完整地看一个Profiler
怎么使用的一个案例
首先在这个TorchunPU Profiler的
Profile接口之前
会进行一个扩展的一些配置
然后这里面包括AIC Matrix
它这里设置成了Pipe Utilization
就是它会统计一些
搬入或者计算Pipe的
一个指令的套时和占比情况
然后Profiler Level这里设置成了Level 1
以及它会把那个Data精简的
这个开关给关闭点
然后在Profiler内部
它还设置了具体
我们要怎么去采集数据
这个通过这个Schedule去进行设置
然后Schedule里面
这些对应设置的参数
可以看一下右下角的这张图
首先它设置了Schedule first
就是在重复次数之前
首先跳过十轮的一个运行数据采集
然后每一次重复采集的时候
首先跳过的一个次数
当前设置为0
然后预热的次数设置为3
这三次也会进行性能数据的采集
最终采集的是Active的30次运行的一个性能数据
这里Repeat设置为1
所以最终会输出一个性能数据的文件夹
然后把它存放
它这个性能数据存放的位置
就是这里设置的Result Path
然后这个性能数据实际调用采集的时候
它采集的这个函数
并不是Traten的Kernel标记的这个函数
而是调用这个Kernel外部的这个函数
如果这个函数内部调用了多个算子
那它这里采集Profiler采集到的性能数据
也就是多个算子的一个性能数据情况
最终的结果就会保存在对应的Output的路径下
然后我们常看的是这个KernelDetails的表格
和OP Statistic的表格
首先来看一下KernelDetails的这个表格里
采集的数据是什么
这里面采集的数据每一行
就是之前我们Active的这个
每一次性能数据采集的这个轮次的数据
包括会看这个轮次运行的一个性能耗时情况
还有发射的核数
以及这个Import的Shape或者是Data Type这些信息
如果还启用了Pipe Utilization
那后面还会有一些指令计算
还有搬运的一些性能耗时和占比的一些数据
然后每一次Active的轮次就会产生一行这样的性能数据
同时我们可以看到它的Step ID是从3开始的
是因为我们之前Warmup的时候设置为了3
所以它会跳过前三次的一个性能程序的运行
不采集前三次的数据
然后后面因为Active设置成了30
所以这里面会采集到30行的一个性能数据
而另一个是OP Statistic
这个主要是会把所有轮次的一个性能采集数据取
去进行一个统计运算
最后得到的是整个算子的
比如说平均性能耗时
还有最大最小的性能耗时
如果我们想评估一个算子的一个性能情况的话
我们常看的就是这个OP Statistic的一个统计数据情况
除了Profiler以外
我们还有其他的一个性能检测的一个工具
叫做MS Proof
这个工具常用的命令有以下的两个
一个是MS Proof
还有一个是MS Proof OP
这两个工具有什么区别呢
首先MS Proof可以通过刚刚Application
后面指定具体执行的一个指令
来采集这个函数级的一个算子的性能耗时情况
比如说一个函数内它可以有多个算子
那这通过MS Proof可以采集到这个函数内多个算子的耗时
这样子的话我们就可以看到整个函数内
哪个算子的性能耗时是最大的
然后通过MS Proof OP
是可以采集到单个算子的一个性能耗时情况
通过刚刚Kernel可以指定我要采集的是哪个算子
然后它采集到数据是这个算子内哪部分的性能耗时最大
比如说它可以采集一些硬件利用率
bank conflict情况等等
它最终可以分析到为什么这个算子执行的这么慢
所以我们常见的流程通常就是用ms proof工具
首先分析函数内部到底是哪个算子的耗时最大
哪个算子执行的最慢
然后再通过ms proof op去打开看这个耗时最长的这个算子内部
因为什么导致它的耗时最长
然后我们展开介绍一下这个ms proof的工具
它的执行方式有两种方式
第一种就是我在ms proof后面直接跟随我们执行的一个脚本的命令
还有一种就是通过杠杠application去指定
我只要执行的脚本的命令
然后除了刚刚application这个参数以外
还有刚刚output可以指定输出目录
还有ARC code可以打开ARC code的一个数据采集的开关
打开之后它可以采集到ARC matrix相关的一些性能指标
比如说Pipe Utilization还有计算的一些利用率
还有memory的这些指标
默认是deport值
deport值就是把这些性能指标全部采集
然后它试用的场景我们之前也介绍了
常用于看一个多个算子的一个性能耗时情况
它是用于分析函数级别的一个性能瓶颈
然后最终这个MSProof执行完之后
它也会有一个可视化的一个性能报告
这样方便我们去分析整个算子的一个全链路的一个性能
然后我们这里以一个简单的一个加法的算子为例
如果通过MSProof执行这个add kernel的话
可以看到下面这个输出目录的一个结构
输出文件的一个结构
首先它会有device测和host测的一个采集数据
这里采集的都是二进制的一个原始数据
这些数据其实都是人类不太可读的一些数据
所以我们主要看的其实是通过minerstudio解析的一些
CSV的表格文件
比如说这里有opSummary
它统计的是算子级的性能
然后如果一个算子被多次运行的话
那它会安续统计到
这个算子多次运行的一个
每一次的性能数据的情况
然后opStatistic就是算子调用统计
它相比于这个summary的差别
就是如果一个算子被多次统计的话
那它统计到的就是一个算子平均的一个性能情况
还有apiStatistic是api接口的一些调用的统计
还有tasktime是task耗时数据
最后会生成一个json文件是一个可视化的文件
然后我们把这个json文件放在minerstudioinside下
就是可以生成这样的一个可视化的视图
然后这里面因为我们通过MSProof
执行的是add kernel这一个算子
那它这里就会显示着单个算子的一个耗时情况
但它不会转世
它不会去分析统计这个算子
kernel内部的一个耗时的细节
然后如果我们通过MSProof
执行了多个算子的话
采集了多个算子性能数据的话
那它在这个可视化的视图里面也会有多个算子的这样子的一个性能的统计
这样可以直观地看出来
哪个kernel哪个算子它的耗时是最大的
然后再展开介绍一下MSProof OP这个工具
它可以通过刚刚kernel name去指定
我需要采集哪个算子的一些细节的性能指标
如果刚kernel name并不进行指定的话
那它默认就是采集的是调度的第一个算子的性能指标
然后可以通过刚刚warmup去设置一些日月次数
还有AIC matrix去设置需要采集的性能指标
就包括右侧的这些所有的性能指标
这个其实在之前Profiler的那个工具里面
我们也展开介绍过
而默认值是default
就是会把这些所有的指标都进行采集
采集完成之后
它会输入对应指标的这个对应的表格性能数据
然后以及最终的一个可视化的二进制文件
然后把这个二进制文件同样放在MindStudio Insight里面
我们可以在Details里面看到这些性能数据的一个分析结果
比如说包括了BaseInfo
就是测试性能采集的这个算子的kernel
还有它的一个性能耗式
以及这个kernel是一个vector的类型
还是一个cube的类型
还是一个mixed类型
还有它发射的一个逻辑核的数量
等等这些信息
然后第二个部分是computer workload analysis
这个主要是分析的是一些
比如说计算单元
搬运单元这些耗时占比等等这些信息
然后第三个部分就是memory的一个workload analysis
主要看的是这些不同memory下的一些读写带宽速度
比如说这里就展示了GM到LR cache的一个读写速率
以及UB到vector的读写速率
最终这个mindstudioinsight工具
还会根据这个分析结果去给一些提示
比如说当它发现你的带宽利用率比较低的时候
它会提示
对你进行提示
看是否需要对带宽利用率进行优化
这个数据的分析
除了使用mindstudioinsight以外
我们还可以使用一些agent skills去固化一些我们的分析的手段
来判断整个酸子性能的
对算子的性能做一些分析结果和诊断
比如说可以通过读采集的一些数据
然后计算算术强度
然后通过这个算术强度是否小于50来判断我们的算子的整个算子的瓶颈类型在哪里
如果这个算术强度小于50说明我数据搬运的耗时占比比较大
那我就优化方向就会是优化内存访问的模式
而如果是大于等于50
那说明它的计算的逻辑可能占比比较大
那它就会推荐你优化一些计算逻辑
除了判断瓶颈类型以外
还可以
Agent Skills还可以去计算内存带宽利用率
还有计算单元的利用率
以及进行一些bank冲突的分析
最后提供一些诊断建议
比如说当发现GM到UB的利用率小于30的时候
它会认为这是一个低的带宽利用率
它会推荐你检查内存访问模式
然后比如说发现Cube利用率比较低的时候
它会建议你去检查矩阵分块的一个策略
还有当bank group的conflict大于0.1的时候
它会推荐你比优化数据快的大小
之前介绍的MS proof的运行
其实都是在深层上去运行
然后采集到的性能数据
然后我们还可以通过仿真测试
去生成具体的指令的流水图
仿真测试的手段就是在MS proof的后面
加上simulator这个值
然后指定具体需要测试的kernel名字
以及后面还需要加一个仿真器的类型
仿真器类型我们可以通过mposmiinfo去查看得到使用什么
然后后面同样是也可以加那个aicmatrix采集的性能指标
最终输出的文件有两个可视化文件
一个是trace.json文件
还有一个是.bing文件
然后这两个可视化文件的差别是在于这个json文件
其实是可以放在chrome浏览器里面直接打开的
我们可以看一下这两个可视化文件打开后的结果
第一个.bing文件放在mindstudioinsight里面
打开之后可以看到这个界面上首先是有一些工具栏
然后展开可以看到下面显示就是不同的核上面
包括cube或者vector还有一些并行运算的逻辑核
的一些具体的pipe的数据
然后还有不同pipe上运行的一些指令的信息
然后点开单条的指令就可以看到这条指令的detail信息
这是我们采集到整个流水图的情况
然后chrome上去打开json文件其实展示的是一样的内容
只不过差别是如果是在mindstudioinsights上
我们得用wasd来对整个流水图进行左右移动或者是放大缩小
然后在chrome上的话其实我们也可以使用鼠标
对整整个流水图进行拨放以及左翼和右翼
然后以上这部分就是介绍了算子性能测试的一些工具
然后之后我们来看一下具体算子进行调试优化的一些比较经典使用的案例
第一个案例就是我们可以通过Tiling策略去提升性能
常见情况就是比如说把GPU上运行的算子往NPU上迁移的时候
我们通常会发现会产生比如说UBO flow密存递出的种情况
或者是性能开销NPU上的性能会比GPU差很多
原因是因为它的NPU的核数其实比GPU少很多
那直接把算子迁移过来之后会导致发射的逻辑核的数量会远大于物理核的数量
这个情况会产生一些严重的启动以及调度的开销
我们可以通过调整Tiling策略来缩减这些核数
使得发射的逻辑核的数量等同于实际物理核的数量从而提升性能
比如说下面的这个例子
在GPU上它的运行核数可以设置为B乘以K除以BlockK的这么一个数量
然后这时候在GPU上只要访问对应切分的Block的位置
就运算直接进行B型运算就可以了
但是在NPU上的话因为它核数较小
所以就要把核数缩减为B乘以BlockK的大小
而在NPU内部可以对K种去进行一个破循环的一个运算
然后Tiling的话除了可以去提升性能以外
不同的Tiling策略同样也可以去避免一些内存overflow的问题
比如说我们下面第二个案例就是通过TileCube的loop
去规避一些LEBuffer内存越界的问题
这个案例是因为我们编析目前支持单个Metamode的OP的分析以及切分
如果存在多个Metamode的话
可能会因为分析不够准确
导致我们的编析没有进行切分
从而影响LEBuffer与overflow
这时候我们就可以通过TileCube的这个编译提示
来告诉编译体需要做进行切分
比如说以FlashAttention的这个算子为例
首先它会漏的一个Q指振
然后会进行一个破循环
在KV轴进行一个迭代的运算
然后在这个破循环内部先会进行一个Q矩阵和K矩阵的一个成绩运算
得到QK矩阵的一个结果
这里的这个第二点DOT就会产生一个Metamode的运算
然后在后面QK矩阵的结果通过Vector的运算之后得到P矩阵
P矩阵再和V矩阵进行一个矩阵的成绩得到最终的PV的成绩结果
然后这里的话同样这里的PV的矩阵成绩
T2.DOT也会产生一个Metamode的运算
这就是DOTMetamode的一个场景
在编译期分析的时候
首先Metamode的运算
它的输入是在L1Buffer上的
输出是会存放在L0CBuffer上的
而L1Buffer是512KB的大小
L0CBuffer是128KB的大小
假设我们Q矩阵是128×128×F16的一个shape
K矩阵是128×512×F16的一个shape
在两个矩阵成完之后
得到的矩阵成的结果就是128×512×F32的一个shape
这个数据就会是256KB
那编译期就会发现这个Metamode结果之后
这个数据的大小会因为放不下
会大于L0C的大小
所以会自动的对它进行切二的一个处理
来使得这个QK结果能够在L0C下面放得下
然后再看第二个PV的一个矩阵成绩
PV的矩阵成绩的话
P的数据大小是128KB
V的数据大小也是128KB
在开启DoubleBuffer的场景下
开启L1的DoubleBuffer的场景下
那它刚刚好占满了整个512KB的L1Buffer的大小
那这时候因为编辑只会分析DangleMetamode的结果
所以它会认为这个矩阵是分得下的
它就不会对它进行Tel切分
但是实际我们可以看到这个Q矩阵
它是在复循环之外的
也就是说它的生命区间是贯穿整个程序运算的
那这时候我在L1Buffer的内存里面就不能只考虑有P和V的这两个Buffer
还需要考虑这个QBuffer一直存在
那这时候在开启它Buffer的场景下会发现
它的内存相加就一定会大于L1Buffer的最大的这个内存大小
那这时候如果编辑器没有对它切分
那就会导致这个L1Buffer overflow的问题
所以我们就可以在前端对这个
这个第二个Metamode的这个条件多少头运算
对它去加一个compare hint
加上这个TelCubeLoop为二的这个切分的一个提示
这样来告诉编辑器这个部分的Metamode也是需要进行切分的
从而防止L1Buffer的一个overflow的问题
规避内存overflow的问题除了加那个TelCubeLoop的compare hint以外
我们还有一些其他的compare hint是可以添加来规避一些内存overflow的问题的
比如说这里的案例3
它是使用MetDiscreteMemoryAccess去规避UbioFlow
这个compare hint是用于哪呢
主要是用于非连续的数据搬运的时候
因为非连续的数据搬运会在我们编译过程中进行扩轴
那扩轴之后就很容易导致UbioFlow
比如说下面假设有一个数据的Shape是N乘E乘F32
那它的尾轴是E乘F32只有四季节
不是三十二季节对齐的
编译器就会对它进行扩轴
扩轴之后它会把尾仇拉到三十二季节对齐
那整个Shape的扩轴后的Shape大小相比于扩轴之前就会扩大八倍
这个内存的量就很容易导致UbioFlow
然后优化的策略就是针对这些搬运的数据给它打上一个Made Discrete Memory Access的一边提示
把整个Load Store的操作退化为标量阶级操作
它就会避免产生UbioFlow的一个结果
比如说右边的这个示例
展示了怎么去打那个Comparing的标签
然后首先是需要import这个相关的一个组件
然后在创建A指针的时候
我们可以看到它把Stri的设置成了1M
那这里的M就表示了最后一位它不是连续的
那这时候在编译器编译的时候
它就会进行自动的一个扩轴
那我们为了防止UbioFlow
我们就可以把那个A指针
Load后的结果给它打上一个Compare Hint
Make Discrete Memory Access的这个Compare Hint
来把它退化为标量进行操作
避免UbioFlow
最后一个部分是给大家介绍一些
我们常用的一些编译优化的选项
以及编译调试的手段
首先左边这张图先给大家介绍一些
常用的性能优化的一些编译的选项
比如说MultiBuffer是开启乒乓流水
开启乒乓流水之后是可以使得程序并行执行的
所以可以提升性能
下个编译选项是Limit Auto Multibuffer
它是设置了看乒乓流水
需要在不同的片上内存的哪些内存上进行启用
默认的话是No L0C
就是只在L0C以外的内存上去启用乒乓流水
L0C本身不启用乒乓流水
原因是因为启用乒乓流水之后
需要占用额外的一些内存空间
那L0C本身它只有118KB
比较小
如果开启乒乓流水就很容易导致L0Coverflow的问题
所以我们一般默认设置为No L0C
然后是Uniflag
它可以设置Cube搬出的时候
是否要按照整块进行搬出
这个仅限
这个对起
就是只有整块数据
数据对起的场景下可以使用
如果产生尾块的话
就不能使用这个选项
它可以加速FixPipe的一个数据的搬出速度
然后
第四个LimitAutoMultiBufferInfoLocalBuffer的话
是可以设置是否需要在GM中去开启MultiBuffer
来启用CV的流水运行
Force就表示启用
这个选项通常会结合下面的这个SetWorkspaceMultiBuffer使用
如果设置为2就说明GM的MultiBuffer设置为了2份
4就是设置成了4份
我们通常会设置为4
性能会更好一些
然后是TileMixVectorLoop和TileMixTuberLoop
是两个切分的一个选项
切分的逻辑其实我们在之前的案例里面刚刚介绍过
然后这两个选项通过切分就可以防止Tuber的Tuber核
或者是Vector核出现内存overflow的一个情况
而且它会比先进行Tile
在执行整个程序的性能效果会更好一些
然后左边这些都是一些性能优化的相关的编译选项
然后同样我们可以通过额外的两个编译选项去尝试
规避一些Kernel运行时候的一些超时或者卡死的问题
可以在Kernel的最后去
Kernel的参数的最后去尝试添加
InjectBlockAll或者是InjectBarrierAll
去来开启核间同步和核内同步
开启了核间和内同步之后
可能就可以规避这些超时或者卡死问题
同样也可以用它来去隔离看什么部分的问题
以上就是我这边介绍的一些算子调试
还有算子性能测试的工具
以及表示优化的案例这些内容
然后之后第四部分算子性能优化
我们就交由李田老师来进行给大家继续的一个分享
小伙伴们大家好
接下来由我向大家讲解
我是本次玛丽全开特级的讲师
生疼看生态技术专家李田
然后下面由我向大家介绍一下
TraderSense的算子性能优化的一些常见场景
首先我们先看第一个
就是以FlashAttention为例
我们先看它算子测的一个常见场景
就是第一个就是说是
我们社区的Trader接口
对两个Tensor取最大值
以及做一个Reduce的一个最大值
他们针对于边界NAN数据的一个处理
它带来了一个性能的影响
首先社区它在这个接口里面
它其实是有一个PropagateNum的一个接口
然后它默认走的是上面这一个
默认上面这一个它其实本身
它处理的原则是遵循忽略NN
然后返回非NNN的最大值
也就是说它其实最后生成的是
Arase的这个方言
那么它其实就是说是
只要我比较这两个数
我其中任何一个数是NN的话
那么我结果就会返回另外一个数
即举个例子
就是说对于Arase这个方言
如果我比1.0和NN它其实返回是1.0
那么第二种场景就是说是这个PropagateNN
NN等于PropagateNNN
然后它默认生成的是Arase的另外一个方言
然后它的意思就是说是我会传递NN这个数值
那么也就是说只要我在比较两个数
从任何一个是N
那么结果也就是NN
然后举个例子就是说是如果我现在比这个1.0和NN
它就返回是NNN
然后因为我们一般调用这个接口的时候
我们不会设置这个Propagate的这个属性
所以它默认其实是走的是上面
那么我们底层的生同的硬件指令
它其实的行为是底下
所以就等于说在不设置这个属性的情况下
我们为了处理这个NN的这个边界场景
我们就需要额外的就添加了一些软实现
就是用硬件去模拟
特别用软件去模拟
那么在这种情况下
因为你添加一些指令做这个软实现
所以我们就需要一些额外的UV空间
那么因此在实际使用的过程中
如果大家处理的时候是没有这个边界数据
那么其实是推荐第二条指令的
那么举一个案例就是说是
我在Flash Attention这个算子里面
我经常会去更新逆行中的最大指嘛
那么社区的写法是这样子的
那么这个就是说的是第一种
然后它会有一些软实现
所以它需要一些额外的空间
然后如果在没有边界数据场景的情况下
我们推荐是第二种
因为第二种它的使用就是说是对于这个max和reducemax
我们都需要加一个propagateN等于propagateout
那么在这种情况下
我们其实底层的升腾指令
它是一条指令就可以做到了
所以因此它就可以省UV的空间
然后这是第一个
然后第二个旁间的就是随路转制
首先就是说是我们原生的一些Trading社区
它针对Attention类的一个泛化写法
它是面向GPU设计一些语言
所以它会有一些GPU友好的
例如这个随路转制的搬运行为
所谓随路转制的搬运行为
就等于说是假设我在GM上
我的数据是一个16x32的一个连续
那么我其实搬到片内的时候
假设搬到片内L1
然后我要给DOT用的时候
我是希望把它内轴和外轴交换一个位置的
那么社区的写法
它是通过在makeblockptr的时候
它是把这个strad内轴和外轴的strad交换了一下
所以在IR上体现
其实整个的搬运行为
它的内轴的strad是不为1
但是外轴strad是1
那么在这种情况下
它就相当于实现了一个随路转制
然后它做完这个随路转制
它会给后面的cube盒去用
去做一个metamod计算
那么我们升腾上的硬件指令
在A2 A3上
我们其实是不支持这种随路转制的
所以因此现在为了功能
我们其实是把这种随路转制
非连续性的
我们是推化成标量去计算的
然后它性能会比较差
所以为了性能的话
我们是推荐右边这种实现的
也就是说你正常的搬运
就按它的内外轴去搬运
大家可以看到就是左边和右边
左边相当于它strad掉了个位置
然后它的这些shape呀block
shape它都是掉了个位置
那么我们右侧的话就不要掉下这个位置
然后load进来以后
我们去掉一个显示的transpose
然后去实现它这个转制
这样子的好处是
首先你的搬运是一个连续的搬运
它不会推化成标量
它的性能会比较好
其次是
有些小伙伴可能会觉得
这个transpose
它应该是一个vector的一个行为
但是其实升腾上的cube指令机
它是有做这种transpose的能力
所以实际在变运器实现上
它这条transpose会因烂到matmole里面
也是会用一条指令给做掉的
这样整个它的性能会比较好
所以在遇到attention类的算子
我们一般是右矩阵
位头会有一个transpose的一个场景
然后我们需要推荐用右边实现
它的性能会更好
下一个的话
就是说是这个1比2做
然后这个是集中于编译器测
首先我们先介绍一下
什么是1比2
就是对于升腾硬件上
我们会有一个CV核的一个配比
所谓CV核的配比
就等于说是一个cube核
它对应几个vector核的处理单元
那么我们目前硬件是1比2
也就是说一个cube的计算结果
它会分给两个vector去做
那么编译器这个功能
我们会在CV这个场景下我们会自动去使呢
也就是说对于A3来说我cube计算的结果我会放到GM上去
M上去然后再从GM漏的到UB上去做一个计算
那么在这种过程中我们会把GM搬到UB这个过程会自动1200
然后就相当于每个vector核算一半的数据
那么编译器测做这个事情它会有一些限制
例如说它无法实能1比2
什么叫无法实能1比2
就举个例子
就比如说你Metamode的结果后面跟了两条reduce的操作
但是第一个vectorreduce是高轴
第二个reduce是内轴
像这种reduce轴我们都是没有办法切的
所以在这种情况下是没是实现不了把它均分成两个核去做的
所以在这种情况下我们为了功能的正确性
我们就只能限制一半的vector核工作
另外一半vector核不工作
避免重复操作影响精度
然后我们举个例子
就比如说我Metamode结果
然后最后给两个elementwise的操作
大家可以看到它其实是算了一个64乘以F16的一个数据
那么如果编译器它自动实能成功的话
首先我们会相当于你第一个vector核它处理前32
第二个vector核处理后面32个
那
它是怎么实现的呢
它其实是用这个extract slice
通过填一个offset去实现
而这个offset大家可以看到
它是一个getsublockidx
它就相当于是
分别去获取和0的id和和1的一个id
所以对于和0来说
那它就拿的是前半段
和1它就拿的是后半段
拿到正确的数据以后
然后中间的计算
它都可以一分为二去计算
然后算完以后
那我们就需要把这32个数据存回去
存回去那么也是和0
它要存前32个数据
和1存后32个数据
在这种情况下
我们就会也是通过这个offset的机制去实现
这个offset其实就是这个sublock的这个id的和number
就通过这种去实现
那么在这种情况下
假设遇到我们一些切不了的一个场景
那么我们为了避免它精度的情况下
那么我们会限制只有和0在工作
所以我们会加一个if的判断
这个if判断大家可以看
它就其实是拿这个sublock的和的number
然后它就会去跟这个0比较
只有相等的时候
它才会进这个off循环
那么它其实它的语义就是相当于
我只有和0的情况下
我才会进底下这个分支
那么这样子的话
它能保证一个精度的正确性
但是这里就会有一个问题
就是它的性能不好
因为1比2的话
本身两个wector核可以并行去处理
现在变成了只有一个核去处理
这样子的性能会很差
那么在这种情况下
对于编译器
其实是应该要使能
但是因为现在
比如说泛化场景
它暂时没有使能的情况下
其实EssenNPUIR
它也是提供了前端的编程接口
然后来自动的切分wector数据
然后使能1比2优化
然后我们举一个例子
就是说是这个1比2算子
我怎么去通过手写这个算子
达到这个1比2使能
首先我们在这个过程中
就是遇到一些动态的场景
在这种情况下
编译器是切不出来的
那么在这种情况下
前端是可以自己去做
然后我们以A5为例
就是A5芯片
我们FixPipe
也就是数据从Cube
搬到Wector的这条指令
我们新增了一个叫FixPipe
DualDest Mode
然后这个它可以去设置
你到底是暗行一分为二
分给两个Wector核还是暗列
所以我们可以通过设置
这个就可以完成数据
像两个Wector和写
那么在这个过程中
我们提供的接口有以下几个
第一个是AL
AL是Athena Language的缩写
AL.Subvector ID
它其实本质上就是get你这个Subblock IDX的Number
第二个是AL.SubvectorNumber
就是get你现在是有多少个核
因为我们目前是1比2
但是为了泛化性的去思考
那以后我们的配比可能是一个1比N
然后第三个就是Tensor Extracts Less
它其实就是说是我一个切片读取
就是相当于对于Cube来说
我不同的Vector
我可能要读不同的数据
那么我就是从一个大块的数据里面去取我实际上要读的一个数据
它支持可以去设置Offset
Stread等等
然后同理和Extracts Less对应的就是这个Inserts Less
Inserts Less它其实就是切片写回
就比如说我两个Vector分别算完一半的数据以后
我又要给Cube里面去写回
那么在这种情况下
我们也是可以支持它填你的OutsetStread等信息
然后完成两个Vector和我正确的一片Cube和里面分别去写的功能
介绍完以下接口以后
我们来具体看一下
就是我们还是以FlashAttention为例
那么我们一般情况下
一个FlashAttention它算完了一个Dot
它需要FixPap再重新搬出到UB上
如第43号来看
我们来解释一下这号
正好就是说是我FixPap
我的Source是前一个Dot的一个结果
它的TargetShape就是它输出就是B
BlockM和BlockN的一个大小
那么它的Dest就是这个PVUB
就是搬到Vector上去
然后这里是我们FixPap的一个私有格式的一个转换
就是数据layout的一个转换
然后如大家所示
这里可以看出来它其实是设置了RosePlate
它的意思就是说是我一个BlockM和BlockN的一个数据
我是按一分为二
也就是说每一个Vector核
它会拿到二分之BlockM和BlockN的一个数据
那么对于底下的Vector核来说
它拿到了一个二分之BlockM和BlockN
那么它其实就相当于拿到这个数据以后
它进行了一个计算
然后在这个过程中
对于一些中间变量的一些申请
就是相当于在UB上
我们的空间都需要进行一个减半
然后这就是一个手写的一个基础的一个实例
所以大家如果遇到编译器册没有实现1比2的情况下
为了性能大家可以尝试利用提供的接口去自己写一下这个1比2
然后下个场景就是编译器册的这个TelCubeWaterloop的一个优化
所谓的这个优化
其实本质上是因为我们硬件核里面所有的空间都是有限的
比如说对于Cube来说
它做一个基础的一个计算
你数据从JM搬到片上L1的时候
L1只有512KB
我们默认是会开double buffer的
所以在这种情况下
其实你的左矩阵和右矩阵加起来只能容纳256KB
那么计算完的结果它会放在L0C上
L0C上我们现在只有128KB
因为在这种情况下
所以经常会出现
比如说我们的基块比较大的情况
那它L1或者L0C放不满的情况下
我们就要对它做一个基础的一个切分
如左边这个来做事
就比如说我现在这个for有两层循环
然后里面是一个C0
那对于这个C0它其实就是做了一个mat mode
就如我刚刚所提
对于一条mat mode它的左矩阵加右矩阵是要按256KB去算的
然后它的dest是要按128KB算的
但凡超过
那么我们这个基础的指令就是放不下
放不下的情况下
我们就相当于针对于它的轴做了一个再次的切分
我们举个例子
就比如说我的左矩阵现在M
就是M乘K的那个M
现在假设是10240
那么这种是肯定放不下的
那我们就可以给它切
假设我就切十分
那么你切了十分以后
其实你内部的这个TELC0的大小
其实就是10240除以10
其实也就是1024
当然1024可能还是放不下
我这里只是举了一个例子
然后同理对于Vector来说
因为Vector它实际上是256KB
但是对于编译器测来说
我们其实只能用到192KB
那么在这种情况下
它也是有可能放不下
放不下那也是要这样进行一个切分
所以在这种切分的情况下
它就能保证你整个能放下
那么在这种情况下
它还有一个好处
就是说是我能降低AIC核和AIV核交互的频率
那它是怎么实现的
就是说
比如说我对于这么一个操作来说
我理论上我不切之前
我为了C0能放下
那我就肯定要减小机块的大小
然后我们因为Flash和Tension
或者说是一些典型CV场景
它V0和C0之间存在依赖
所以在这种情况下
在你减小机块的情况下
然后那你C0算完给V0
所以你每算一次C0
这里就要设置一个同步点
然后前一个C0执行完
V0才能启动
那么这样子的话
就像我每做一次同步一次
每做一次同步一次
那么我如果通过这种切分
我有个什么好处
就相当于我可以做完这内部的这个4G
做完这么多次循环后
我再去同步一次
因为我做这么多次循环以后
其实我的数据块就比较大嘛
那我同步一次
我未给Vector
那我就能打满Vector
的利用资源
所以在这种情况下
它就其实是降低AIC核和AIV核的
一个数据交互的一个频率
然后在这个过程中
同时我们这个切块大型
应该配合条大
然后保证你切分后
AIC核AIV的利用率
然后就举一个例子
就比如说像这样
这个就是我提到
就是说是假设你不做切分
那你其实就是这里零算完
跟一同步再跟二同步
但我现在可以把
这两组一起算完再同步一次
那它其实整个的
同步频率就降低了一倍
然后这里有一个注意点
就是说是我们
TelMix Vector Loop和TelMix Cube Loop
它分别就是对Vector进行
Subtelling和对Cube进行Subtelling
我们是有一些编译选项的
这个编译选项刚才宋磊
应该也已经有了介绍
然后配合它们的话
我们就可以进行一个对AIC核
AIV核进行再次切分
然后在这个过程中
我们不需要就是因为
Tube和Vector我们的这个切分策略
可以设置不同
那么在这种情况下
算子开发者也可以结合
AutoTune配合Telling
然后寻找一个最优的一个性能
然后下面我再介绍编译器测的一个流水优化的一个
首先我们先看什么叫CV Pipeline
CV Pipeline其实本质上就是我们也需要把不同复循环之间的Cube和Vector
尽可能在时序上进行一个并行
这样就可以完成一个流水掩盖的一个目的
那么它是怎么实现的呢
举个例子
大家可以看
就是比如说我们以一个Flash of Tension为例
Flash of Tension是C0V0C1V1
然后它们是有一个依赖关系
即V0依赖C0
C1依赖V0
V1依赖C1
那么在这种情况下
那么它整个的执行序就是相当于
因为我所有的同步点都是
对于第一次复循环
就是C0V0C1V1做完以后
下次复循环
它就是要在这里启动
那么大家可以看到
就是做V0的时候
其实这里都是在等待的空泡
那么在这种情况下
我做CVPIPLINE就会改成这样
就相当于
我同时发射四份C0出去
然后同时发射四份V0C1V1
然后通过调整它流水的互相等待关系
也就是说是
我通过设置V0和C0之间
它们相互等待的那个Flag ID
Flag ID大家可以理解成它们的一个同步点
也就是说是我后面的V0
只需要等这个同步点的C0
那么就是相当于C0做完这个直线以后
它会set这个ID
那么V0就等这个ID
就是一个producer和consumer的一个关系
那么我只要通过设置不同的ID
我就可以达到不同循环间
它们是可以并行
因为它们不存在一个producer和consumer的一个关系
那么在这种情况下
我同时发射多份出去
那这就是四份C0
那么同时发射四份V0
因为这一份的V0它只依赖这里的C0
它可以和下一次的C0是并行
那么其实就是整个流水是进行了一个优化掩盖
那么在这个过程中
我们是可以通过设置
你发射多份C
发射几份C0
也就是说你的并行
中间这个度
我们默认是通过这个workspace去设置的
然后这个workspace的默认数字是2
但是我们也可以设置成4
那么这个的话
其实就是宋磊刚才
宋磊老师刚才介绍的那个变异选项
然后大家可以通过autentune
然后进行一个寻优
然后找一下最优的一个性能
然后在这里有一个小tip
就是说是
其实对于attention类的一个算子
它性能最大的问题
就是说是你这个CV和你的并行
也就是说你的流水优化的是不是很好
所以在这种情况下
可以结合刚才宋磊老师介绍的
怎么去看流水图
跑流水
是介绍的
怎么去看流水图
跑流水图
然后以及查看CV pipeline以后的IR
是否去确认它这个流水并行
是否是使能的
如果没有使能的话
我们其实也是通过了提供的核件同步
也可以进行控制
那么我们就来看一下
这个是怎么写的呢
大家可以看一下
就是说是因为我们attention类的变种其实很多嘛
那有的时候它牵扯一些
比如说分支控制
因为对于attention它会有一种变种叫spath
那么在spath的情况下
我们就是要根据它不同的mask
要做不同的分支
因此在这种情况下
有可能带了分支跳转
它的整个的流水并行就不是很好
那么其实我们就可以自己通过控制核件同步的接口
那么它主要要实现两点
第一点就是说是我们手动要控制路浦的循环保证
和cv的一个代码序
保证cv是一个可并性的一个流水
什么叫一个可并性的流水
就是说是它是一个有向无环图
因为我们其实本质上这个cv流水
是因为我可以把那个存在依赖关系的
尽可能打包在一起发射出去
但是如果你是一个有向有环图的情况下
那它就没有办法
假设我现在就是一个c0和v0
那我c0的结果给v0
然后v0的结果再反位给c0
那它其实就是一个图
那么在这种情况下
你很难区分出来它这个依赖的这个边界
它是没有办法做
那么在这种情况下
我们就可以通过那个workspace交货
然后再手写load和start
这个当然是指就是能变形起来的
然后第二种的话就是说是
它手动控制cv核件的一个同步
保证流水的一个并行
那么我们提供出来的这个接口
大家可以看它分别是那个pro
就是相当于producer的这个核
和consumer的核
和他们等待的ID
这句就相当于说是
我vector核在执行完
我会设置一个0的同步点给cube核
那么底下wait就相当于是cube会等这个vector的这个和0的这个ID等于0的这个同步点
那么在这种情况下我们就可以通过
比如说是
当然这个是一个简易的就是最简单的一个设置
因为在后面随着新平的一个演进它指令发生了变化
所以我们会再提供一些流水线之间的一个信息
就比如说像这一行的话
它其实就是说是cube核等vector和ID为4
也就是说是mte1这条流水线要等mte3
mte3它就是相当于是vector的搬出
mte1就相当于是cube的计算
因为是这样就是我们在a5上我们fixtype是可以直接从up搬到l1的
那么搬到l1以后那么l1就要进l0a和l0b进行一个计算
所以它的流水线就是mte1的mte3
呃在这种情况下我们就是可以通过设置这些flag id
然后达到它整个的一个流水控制
嗯
介绍完手动写流水以后
呃我们今天的课程
呃我介绍部分就结束了
然后这个是我们的一些呃开源的一些资料
嗯
然后呃有我先向大家介绍一下
就是说是我们生疼的trainers呢
其实主要是由两部分组成
第一个是算子的开发入口
第二个是编程范式兼容的trainers呢
和面向生疼清河的编译优化
呃使能三方框架接入的assin npoir
目前这两个仓已经全部已经开源了
左边是trainers呢
然后右边是assin npoir
欢迎大家start
然后大家可以扫着两个码跳转到开源仓
我们的社区除了教学资料线上视频以外
也会定期的进行一个直播的教学
呃
然后这就是我们历史的一些教学的呃宣传
然后同时我们也有固定的双周的sig线上会议
然后呃大家可以从线上日历找到那个会议链接
并参加其中呃
时间是每双周的周四下午两点
同时大家也可以扫这个码呃
加上小助手
小助手会拉你进入sig微信群
欢迎大家踊跃参与
与社区共建
前面的话
我们介绍的玩法一
我相信已经有小伙伴
在活动的issue下面
已经评论答案了
那么本次直播互动的
三道题的答案
前两道单选题是B和A
最后一道多选题是AB
评论区全部答对的
前五名小伙伴
可以私信小助手
领取奖品
那么没有抽到奖品的
小伙伴也不要灰心
课后作业和学习笔记
都有机会拿到奖品
大家可以扫码
报名看训练营
更多挑战及丰富的奖品
等待大家
大家可以扫屏幕上的
二维码预约下一场直播
没来得及观看直播的
开发者也可以在B站搜索
深层看
观看回放
那么以上就是今天
马力全开特辑直播的全部内容
我们下期再见